hey was ein krankes haus dann noch hier
mit balkon also das würde ich ohne mit
der wimper zu zucken direkt nehmen wenn
ich das geld aber habe ich leider nicht
das noch ein bisschen werbung schalten
hier kann man konditionen da ist einfach
die dusche und da kann man eigentlich
gar nichts
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut
herzlich willkommen noch mal schön dass
sie da sind wir gerade mittag wollten
erstmal das essen gehen und danach das
war sogar maries idee und zwar fahren
wir immer also immer sie wollte nicht in
köln gesagt wenn wir dieses kölnerin
aber ich sehe doch ein bisschen gern
keiner dass auch ich bin kein geboren
ich bin immer mindestens einmal der
woche in köln gewesen in meinem ganzen
leben aber rund 40 meter von ihm weg
leute ich bin kein oder auf jeden fall
auf dem weg wenn ich zu ihr fahren
diesmal auf der linken seite der
autobahn so ne fertighaus welt also da
gibt es richtig viele häuser die halt
einfach fertig sind also die kann man
kaufen und dann werden die innerhalb von
zwei drei tage auf dem grundstück gebaut
also nur das gerüst des hauses in
ausstattung natürlich weggelassen und
wir kaufen heute das günstigste haus der
welt
da muss ich mal ganz zu versetzen und
zwar die sahara und hat alex gestern ja
seht ihr diese bäume und die ganze nicht
so schön nämlich so und alex endlich
vergessen im kissen abgeschlossen und
dann ist mein hart gegen meinen kopf
geklatscht und jetzt habe ich schon mal
zu machen dann habe ich noch mal gegen
die andere seite dann sieht man es nicht
wir fahren da hin ich bin echt gespannt
weil wie gesagt ich fahre jetzt schon so
lange vorbei und ich wollte ja immerhin
wir schauen uns heute mal die häuser an
ich hoffe dass so interessant für euch
wir uns auf jeden fall weil vielleicht
kann man da ja ein haus kaufen in zwei
oder drei jahren für uns das ist
wirklich dran tun
naja ich nicht okay dass vielleicht wir
sind jetzt
450 meter entfernt davon wie gesagt nur
von weitem gesehen also ich hoffe auch
mal es ist nicht voll da kann man
natürlich ganz nette aufnahme wo man
werde ich die ganze zeit blöd angeguckt
nur leute angekommen da vorne müssen wir
jetzt irgendwo rein und dann bin ich mal
gespannt ich kann es für absolut nicht
einschätzen wie groß das ist aber es
scheint wohl ein paar besucher zu geben
wer kommt eigentlich am mittwoch auf die
idee sich fertig weise anzuschauen außer
wir so hier geht es jetzt rein dass das
schild was wie man von der autobahn
sehen da vorne ist nämlich die autoren
die leute wir sind jetzt drin
das lustige ist wir mussten eintritt
bezahlen 10 euro für drei personen also
wenn ich jetzt hier wirklich interesse
an seinem haus hätte das finde ich ja
schon mal komisch wird sagen jetzt
suchen wir uns mal das schönste aus und
da gehen wir mal rein oder aber ich
könnte jetzt auch gar nicht so wenn ich
das haus hier sehr könnte jetzt nicht
differenzieren ob das ein fertighaus ist
oder ob es irgendwo hin gebaut hat oder
also schon schwierig kommt man hier rein
geht ja sogar sind jetzt die einzige wir
sind jetzt hier in das erste haus rein
gegangen als es ist sogar komplett von
innen ausgestattet geht der stern wird
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr klasse als
flop das war kein besonderes oder so
aber hier würden direkt einziehen
wo kann man hier den preis erfahren
vielleicht haben die russen eine
fleischmann kooperation
wer ein haus gibt es schon sagen wir das
mit einem pool meinte hier gibt es dann
auch einen pool also der ist cool dass
auch ein pool ausgestellt das können wir
ja mal suchen
auch hier ist noch die küche hier könnte
ich dann meine koch videos drehen oder
also sondermittel platte bräuchte ich
auf jeden fall in der nächsten wohnung
oder was auch immer
danach will auf dieser witz gemacht wird
vielleicht gibt es ja ein balkon oder
juni ich finds richtig gut jetzt hier
noch den ball kommen dass wir am besten
sind die werden da alle so wieso ist ja
in ordnung so schön rot hallo ich
bedenken wirken dauert es in hausen zu
stellen so zwei tage dann ist das ganze
haus fertig und sagen eine woche
trotzdem könnte man mal so ein franck
haus machen wenn man so jemanden kennt
ein grundstück hat und so viel geld hat
braucht man dem einfach mal wenn er im
urlaub ist ein haus das thema kurz auf
toilette also wenn man hierzu durch
guckt ich muss ja sagen es wird
eigentlich von haus zu haus krasser dass
da ganz hinten fast in die garage
überhaupt mein auto reine sie zu klein
aus und wenn ich dann später zwei oder
drei autos habe das passt ja gar nicht
also hier folgt jetzt die nummer 8 das
ist das mit dem tool also zumindest auf
dem foto ich glaube nicht dass da jetzt
ein cool dabei ist aber wir können ja
mal gucken es ist auf jeden fall sehr
interessant hier also es lohnt sich mal
hier vorbei zu schauen auch wenn man
zehn euro eintritt in frage kommen alte
106 soll das kaufen können wir ja so und
dass ihr euch ist sowieso immer ich mal
kurz ein geiles pick leute aber es ist
schon sehr hellhörig hier drin also halt
total braucht irgendein t shirt einlauf
lux hause
vor allem das ist ja auch gar nicht
abgetrennt dieses zimmer also irgendwie
komisch hier ist auf jeden fall noch
eine ziemlich große terrasse das ist
alles die garage als man muss sagen das
sieht von außen unglaublich groß aus
allerdings ist das gar nicht so groß und
hier ist eine dusche alter guck mal das
ist eine dusche hier ist die sauna hier
ist es offen
also ich find sie müssen wir mal
komplett irre und passt einfach die
dusche und da kann man eigentlich ganz
ja sehr gut gut dann gehen wir noch
weiter zum nächsten
also ab zum nächsten haus ich glaube das
ist schon das krasseste was man mir so
begutachten kann und zwar effizienzhaus
55 der ganz hinten also auch ziemlich
groß dass von gerade das hat halt so ein
total komisch ist konzept da war
irgendwie alles so bunt durcheinander
gewürfelt und überall wo der halbwegs
platz für war wurde auch dann dieses
feature oder was auch immer also die
sauna die die stadt einfach komplett
irgendwo halt wo man sie so hin packen
kann oder halt auch besser nicht also so
kreuz und quer durcheinander bisschen
komisch
[Musik]
leute sogar mit garten hinter mir also
hier muss ich sagen natürlich finde ich
gut das gefällt mir was ist der
unterschied zur normalen weil sind diese
balken und so und würze kaufen marie
hierzu ausgeben
die haben so eltern weil es diese
deutsche eltern die haben alle so ein
löwe ferne zu hause wie zb meine und er
wird auch nicht abgegeben auch wenn er
schon zehn jahre alt ist
so jetzt sind wir gerade hier nach oben
gegangen also das ist schon geil
also das finde ich wirklich extrem lies
hier ist ein raum hier ist ein raum da
sind zwei räume was ein krankes haus
dann noch hier mit balkon also das würde
ich ohne mit der wimper zu zucken direkt
nehmen wenn ich das geld aber habe ich
leider nicht und ein bisschen werbung
schalten wir aber ins nächste zimmer und
was sagst du gut ne megaschön dass denn
man kann ja nicht morgen bekommen was
ist in der dusche ja kann man da nicht
nur die tür zu ziehen
da kann man doch nicht noch etwas
vorziehen wie komisch ist das denn acht
doch hier ist glas oder welche gegen
gelaufen
guck mal dass man sieht gar nicht dass
seine glas von zwischen es auch in der
küche war noch gar nicht hier von dem
haus also wir sind immer noch die
gleichen
ich bin von dem wenn ich am meisten
überzeugt da müssen ein bisschen sparen
aber dann schauen wir mal an es geht es
hier sogar noch weiter bis 17
also hier gibt es auf jeden fall eine
menge häuser fertighaus welt köln schaut
mal vorbei
mal gucken ob wir noch eins finden was
noch keiner ist als das hier also wo ich
gerade drüber wir sind jetzt hier auch
schon beim letzten haushalt so eine
kleine wasseranlagen hier vor und was
ich wart auch entdeckt habt das
generiert sogar eigene energie mit was
auch immer eine photovoltaik über den
hub das schauen wir uns jetzt noch an
und dann reicht's mir aber auch mit den
häusern habe ich genug häuser gesehen
und dann die sind richtig gut
[Applaus]
also hier der fernseher ist eingerahmt
in einem bilderrahmen aber reicht jetzt
auch mit dem hoyzer und high school
musical durch warum so leid wissen ja
schon wieder zurück und ich muss sagen
ich fand es eigentlich ganz kurz zu
sehen und wird auch das hochhaus am
besten also dieses haus was am größten
war das ist wohl kein fertig aus sondern
im hochhaus und das sind heute von einer
ganz bestimmten marke die halt so mit so
einem balken gebaut sind und das hat
mich sehr überzeugt allerdings ist dass
ich so ein ding was man da in ein zwei
tagen hin bauen kann wie diese fertig
mal dabei und ich muss sagen also ich
würde mir jetzt auch wenn ich mir keinen
also noch gar kein haus also ich denke
noch gar nicht warenhaus oder sonstwas
nach aber ich fand diese fertig weiter
so cool dass so etwas geht aber ich bin
jetzt irgendwie nicht so fern davon ich
fand die irgendwie so ganz komisch
aufgeteilt zb bei dem wo wir am anfang
drin waren
da war einfach irgendwo der dusche
irgendwo eine sauna wenn man die treppe
hochgegangen ist kommt man einfach durch
die dusche gehen also das werk insel
gemacht die haben teilweise gar nichts
richtige wende gehabt
ja aber es war wirklich mal sehr
interessant das ist unerhört also
vielleicht ist das jetzt nicht unser
geschmack gewesen aber es gibt ja
bestimmt menschen denen das gefällt also
lohnt sich auf jeden fall
das war's mit dem wie ich hoffe der
blogger durchgefallen ist wieder ein
anderes video das sie normalerweise von
mir gewohnt seid und abonniert den kanal
jeden tag 19 uhr tickt unser instrument
marie und hier alex steht die kurz und
wir sehen uns morgen ohne marin und
wieder ist aber schade
es macht mir alle daumen nach unten